I actually want to give both of you a
sincere thank you way back in 2008 at
Sundance when collider was this minor
nothing of a sight uh you guys gave me
your time for In Bruges and
um and it meant a lot to me because you
know I hadn't talked to that many anyway
I just want to say thank you from all
the way back then
um was it the year before was that was
it 2008 or 2007 I started in 2005 but
2008 it was still a very small site
compared to what we are now and you guys
giving me your time really meant a lot
to me so I just want to say thank you
well you used it well yeah
it was definitely that interview that
led to collider's growth um so we'll be
expecting those royalties any day
so I I listen I love both of your work
and you you uh I'm just curious if
someone has never seen anything that
you've done before uh what is the first
thing you want them watching and why
oh jeez I don't know and this right now
in Brugge is the first thing that I yeah
so you don't have to say that as well
there's an awful affection for it for
him Bruce you know
um the script of course but just what
that time meant to me personally and
getting the chance to work with this
fella for the first time and Martin for
the first time and um just indelible
friendships kind of created at that
point and this is this is this Banshee
thing is all the sweeter and all the
more meaningful because of Bruges you
know so Bruges will be an anchor for me
yeah I mean the general I was the first
time I worked with John Borman and that
was he taught me everything I know and
I'm tempted to say but that's you know
but he taught me what the essential of
filmmaking you're generally retirement
exactly yeah but there was such a
mentorship that that accrued from that
uh he like there's acting and then
there's film acting in a way that he it
was that that to me was is indelible you
know that that process but the
collaborate race that we had in Bruges
and the the challenge of of the you know
the strength of the material and the
place you had to go that was complicated
especially for Carl with regard to
dealing with what he had to deal with uh
so this idea of being in kind of having
a lot of last but actually been quite
quite a grin totally the kind of the the
kind of uh Comforts that you can create
so that you can actually be really
uncomfortable at the center of it yeah
which was repeated with this you know
with banshees yeah and just the quality
of Americans right and that's it's an
absolute privilege to go at it you know
it really it's really special and we
like plan cheese kind of was delayed a
little bit covertized and the whole
thing is it was like oh no it's like it
was there all of a sudden it's gonna
happen and then it wasn't and this would
have been one of the ones that I I would
agreeves forever if it had happened if I
saw somebody else do it no there was a
certain point in the film where you know
I I might just talk god thank God this
worked out the way it did yeah no I
didn't think it was it was going to be
that somebody else would do it I just
thought that given the times that are in
it yeah these kind of movies are you
know increasingly difficult to to to to
get up there and get out there and
really was Martin's uh you know success
last year with all of that kind of kind
of thing but we're trundling into what
I'm saying is we're trending into a
place where it's going to be almost
impossible to get these films made in
the way that we got them yeah yeah this
was really cinematic deliberately
cinematic deliberately epically
cinematic and then the the story was on
a apparently small lines so we could get
into these characters that were
Intimates and yeah reduced in a way and
the whole thing was done in such a
cinematic way that it's for our Cinemas
it's for Cinemas and to be able to get
those yeah it's like we were blessed we
got it done weren't we and we had honest
to God we had a summer that was such a a
kind of climatic anomaly it was it was
like Greece it was like being on Mykonos
I mean we couldn't find where if we
wanted to shoot in the rain we wouldn't
we'd still be there waiting it was
unbelievable I remember going down to
the beach sometimes and taking a couple
of shots at night and I took a bit of
video on the iPhone of the Waves just
shallow waves they're coming in and
laughing there and I came up and the sky
was all sorts of indigos and oranges and
yeah
I know but of course that's my own
Prejudice no it is based on an
experience of rain and stuff but it was
I've gone to Echo twice before I didn't
see it like because it's all mist and
rain and stuff like that so you're going
into a place that's susceptible to it
with one day where the weather said uh
just in case you didn't remember you
don't yeah yeah and it blew like you
said don't worry we could we had the PO
was the pope saying it was in the hole
we said we go with the interns in scene
would be fine we won't have to shoot out
today and they the wind came along and
blew all the camera the lights from
outside that's all blew them all over
the place halfway across the Atlantic
and more or less we we found it
difficult to work inside because of
noise and because it was very difficult
to have anything we had to block off the
windows and completely seal ourselves in
so as if to say Lads I'm still here by
the way but we uh put his apps and took
it back the guards were smiling on us
how many times did we walk outside the
pub that we were shooting at every time
and we watched the sunset every day and
and it was no like oftentimes on Films
you don't really take moments for
observing the beauty around you that
might be taking place in life the way it
presents itself from time to time here
it was so Stark it was so blinding there
was no first A.D going come on guys we
gotta get back to work production shut
down without it being declared so and we
all walked outside the pub and I
pictures on my iPhone or 40 50 of us
looking just towards the horizon and
that was most days that we shot in the
pool it was just imagine and between
takes yeah like you're walking rainbows
you come out yeah you can draw the
rainbows yeah we walk out and just look
up along the beauty of Apple Island up
along the way that western coast with
the black rocks and sea is coming in
we're just in between takes you go in
there and just plug yourself in yeah it
just contextualize everything and also
was vaguely sort of replenished it for
the next take you didn't have to think
about it all that energy and all that
feeling definitely ended up on screen I
have to ask you though because I'm such
a fan of Martin's work what is he like
in between takes when he's giving you a
note or Direction on what he would like
in the scene is it like just like a word
or two or does he is it more like a
full-on conversation details Steve he's
he's really he really is I mean I
noticed that I think I think because
maybe I had a little bit of a greater
degree of objectivity just
um which is not to say certainty but I I
well I'm [ __ ] 14 15 years older now
so maybe I'm a little bit more in myself
but I could I could observe while being
a subject to the experience I felt I
could observe Martin's process more
clearly than I ever had before in a
lovely way and I just observed him being
so detail-oriented you know and
sometimes it is a word I he felt to me
like he was looser this time around as
well like he wasn't as because sometimes
he really and he deserved the right to
me because he hears it he's writing
music he's not just writing dialogue
there's a musicality to what he writes
as well there's tone there's pitch
there's Pace all those things factor in
as he hears a pen to paper but um but
he's very detailed he's also a great
laugh he loves having a great laugh but
if you look in between takes sometimes
the Braille will be furrowed and he'll
have his little pencil and paper there
and he'll be he'll be you know on top of
you and it's great stuff and open for a
good argument as well like it's a really
it's kind of an ideal situation in what
you dream of as an actor to go to work
in a as part of a collaborative team you
know it really is all of us involved you
know and I found sort of in terms of
they began to emerge a kind of a pattern
with this one in particular much more so
than In Bruges uh that I had a really
sort of I had a really good idea where I
wanted to go with this guy and with the
guy I was playing and uh you so you'd
move in and you'd give it and to me it
worked you know that's who he is that's
how the interaction seemed to work and
Martin would take take he said okay
would you just go and try it try it try
it and it started moving you away from
it and you'd be getting further and
further away and I began to get a little
distressed because I said this has got
turned into a different person I'm not
sure where I need to kind of rationalize
who and how this is possible for this
guy to come out with some of this stuff
but you'd find we'd work through it and
then bit by bit
um you would try it of course because he
is what he is and he was editing in his
head and trying different variations on
a team and so but I was saying but I if
I move into this other place I don't
recognize the guy and it basically is a
question we both talked about it let's
we know there's the guy's trust yeah and
but what there's kind of a pattern I
began to notice that it'll also be able
to move back into that place you would
end up not too far away from where you
started so we had got all these colors
in between but I didn't feel by the end
of it that I had been dragged out of
shape I didn't at all feel I've been
dragged and it was a question he'd be
looking for a little nugget coming from
a different place that he could use on
maybe one line but not necessarily with
the others so that like the the
possibilities that he allowed for
so he had a definite idea which is the
way he was with him Rouge yeah but then
he would throw in a whole pile of car
files that would that would start to
make it something
yeah no absolutely yeah
like basically what we had to do is
relinquish control uh Brendan real quick
I have to ask you I'm a big fan of Todd
Phillips and what he did on Joker I know
that you signed on for the sequel
um what was it about the material that
said I want to be in this movie uh it
wasn't the material which is a great way
it get me out of having to answer any
questions about the material which I
can't yeah it was it was you know it was
the achievement not the first film it
was like wacky I worked I worked with
Joaquin before on the village oh yeah
yeah and so I knew I knew him from then
uh and I that performance I'm still in
awe of it that performance as Joker in
that first movie and it was one of the
most extraordinary achievements I never
had and for Todd to have amazing you
know worst movie around to allow for
that I didn't have to be asked twice I
really didn't in Colin I get the real
quick uh is the Penguin series gonna
happen no idea what the joke is about I
haven't read the script the penguin uh
shooting here in New York I think if
goes ahead and I read the first episode
which was just so tasty and so so
unusual and so unusual as the character
was on the page and what Matt Reeves
kind of envisioned when he was when he
was thinking of this iteration of the
penguin of ours so yeah it'll be I think
six or eight hours I'm supposed to read
episode two and three within the next
week and just a really good company of
people and Matt Reeves is all over it
and sure matters you know borderline OCD
when it comes to his focus and and
trying to do something new and original
and and with feeling and aesthetic and
all that good stuff so it would be I
would love I had such a blast doing that
Steve oh it was so amazing it was just
so much fun you know it's just unbridled
I had so much permission to just do
whatever
on that note I think thank you so much
for your time and seriously congrats
banshees is [ __ ] great thank you